buying a home in 2022 is it hopeless las
vegas now or las vegas real estate now
the sponsors of this next segment they
have the answers let's welcome back our
good friend harvey blankfeld how you
doing harvey great thanks for having me
back jason it's great to see before we
jump into things tell everyone your your
background how long you've been in real
estate in las vegas a little over 21
years now uh moved here from baltimore a
while back and been real estate for
quite a while now and i've seen the
market do a lot of things in that time
and so i can tell you that
buying a home is a challenge but it's
not hopeless i mean and the truth of the
matter is it's a challenge for a good
reason
because everyone should be buying a home
you should own instead of rent this for
sure okay are there ways of if a buyer
is watching right now are there ways
they can get creative when it comes to
making an offer on a house that'll help
them out absolutely because you know you
might be competing against cash offers
or other type of buyers so what you
might want to do is offer the seller
time in the home after close of escrow
so they have time to get out maybe give
them some
occupation occupancy time in the home
afterwards also maybe offer to pay
some of the normal seller expenses in a
transaction might put you over the top
as well and make you look better to
somebody that offers something what are
some other seller transactions that we
should be paying
well you could pay a transfer fee to the
county okay that's normally a seller
expense you could pay some additional
escrow costs uh some title insurance
costs there are traditional costs on the
seller's side that you could say hey you
know what i'm going to pay that and then
make it makes the deal look better the
seller's really looking at one thing
that number at the bottom
and that's what you want to try to make
as attractive as possible for them okay
these are tips that we should be doing
what is stuff we should not be doing
okay so what you don't want to do is
give up some of your rights as a buyer
and some of the contingencies for
instance don't i would never ever advise
a buyer to waive inspection because you
don't know the seller may not even be
aware of some issues with the house they
may probably have never been in the
attic yes there might be a broken roof
trust up there nobody knows about the
other thing is if you want to waive
appraisal waive it but cap it don't
don't say i'm going to waive the
appraisal entirely but i'll waive it up
to a certain amount and i'll pay that
much more than the appraiser says the
house is worth as long as it's within my
range so someone selling a house for 300
000 it appraises for 300 000 you know
there's people that i i shouldn't walk
in and say i'll give you a 3.15 for it
now that we got 350 000 lying around but
you should not go that high above the
valley right yeah what happened is the
house offered at 300 it might have
praised only at 250. and oh my goodness
now i got a 50 000 gap that's cash i got
to come up with a closing in addition to
the normal expenses tied to a buyer why
why buy now
instead of waiting because is the market
going to start to settle or should you
still be buying a house
there's two things that affect the price
of a house interest rates are one thing
and they're still very very good and
then there's the overall price of the
houses themselves in the market in
general right now interest rates are
still great housing prices have gone up
dramatically obviously everyone knows
that recently but they're only slightly
above where they're supposed to be on
the natural curve of housing expense
here in las vegas we were way behind for
the longest time so we've caught it
we've surpassed a little bit we're not
so overpriced that i'd say we're in
trouble in any way shape or form and i
don't see it changing because demand for
houses in las vegas is still hot
for people moving here from other parts
of the country and other parts of the
world harvey we always always appreciate
your time thank you for joining us hey
mike pleasure hey can i can i give a
quick shout out go ahead absolutely what
do you got guys danny and all the guys
over performance physical therapy in
west sahara they're making my knee
better so thank you
yeah the big time knee replacement right
here you're superman now you're ready to
go yeah i'm gonna run a marathon uh
thank you again to las vegas real estate
now for sponsoring this segment give
them a call at
702-203-1165 or visit
lvrealestateradio.com for more
information rocky